you tried some unique therapies yeah and
and I wanted to hear after that yeah
depression depression when you got that
electromagnetic one yeah
so I tried I when I started going to
therapy in 20 when I was 23
they put me on Zoloft because they knew
how great was it in the beginning
amazing
well I could drink nine gin and tonics -
did not get thrown I liked it I liked it
for like a decade though oh I was good I
didn't it wasn't a drinking thing for me
I just liked I liked it oh yeah I loved
it Brockie get up early I felt good
you would you last longer when you had
sex oh I wasn't odd last longer when I
jerked off for sure sure all right same
thing definitely way definitely dude
yeah because you were always looking to
last longer
yeah yeah right yeah you wanted to save
at a certain point is like for I'm the
one I'm gonna have the orgasm what are
we making it last for it uh it's like
Maya what's that in Greek guys pushing
the ball up the hill Sisyphus yeah this
is not yeah like yeah why am i yeah
where you're looking for just the right
thing like what just finish dude I could
press my butt against the corner of the
counter right when I do is that yeah I
believe that because you couldn't man I
was young bro when I was young
yeah great yeah and you just got I don't
know so when people judge other people
for what they're into it's like I used
to press your butthole against the
counter you can see ya know Liam
so it was linoleum - of course it was -
yeah so so I so I did that for a while
and it worked and then it just stopped
working but like after a decade so then
I started doing other [ __ ] and none of
them worked other pills
no but okay so Zoloft neat Ratu other
pills and none of them work yeah so then
I just I think I went on Reddit and and
typed in like alternative depression in
the water yeah next thing you know so
they know they had there was a thing
called TMS which was a transcranial
magnetic stimulation
that's the way the thing I like people
make fun of reddit but it's the only
place by the way read it's the reason
podcasts work yes that it's unorganized
organization it's like it's off the grid
but on the grid it's like an alternative
way to do [ __ ]
so it's this it's what podcast is to
radio reddit is to the internet or
society and transcranial magnetic
stimulation so it's basically like a
tapping thing it's a it feels like
tapping but it's a magnet it's an MRI
beam stimulating a party brain that's
known to cause depression did that for
it's 45 half hour sessions natively
right over like a month and a half
obviously like four days a week did that
four years ago and it worked great
then well it worked great I stopped
taking Zoloft I felt really good I was
on nothing [ __ ] yeah I was I was more
emotional but it was still I was good
yeah I was like I'd cry kind of without
warning like like I would get just like
quickly upset and then I don't gave me a
CH I'll [ __ ] try anything I don't
give a [ __ ] sure why not
[ __ ] but it was like a bad formula
and it was like a cream so that I
started having panic attacks on stage
you're on a CH degree yeah I was on the
clear I was on Barry Barry Bonds is fun
it's like protocol the SPF milkshakes
yeah yeah that's funny yeah it was crazy
so I started having panic attacks on
stage I was like [ __ ] this is not guide
panic attack the night before I did my
Netflix three mics ah yeah so and you
talked about this on one of the specials
you talked about the trans crash yeah
yeah and three months yeah
so so that I did that and then it
started manic Rex I was like f [ __ ] I
guess it works so then I went back on
Zoloft and I still felt good from the
the transcranial but you know I'm always
looking I'll do anything
okay I don't kids or wife or anything
right so
so you uh you did the show in Shanghai
and I'm always looking to just travel
and I'd rather go to to Tokyo than like
Milwaukee right it's like more
interesting right yeah definitely super
unique and right before we got I just
wanna what anything else that you tried
so oh I also try ketamine ketamine the
the drug right but that they do that
clinically now for depression and I
didn't like it other people liked it I
just didn't like it didn't work for me
so so so you just shown Shanghai text
and again I also do Milwaukee but if I'm
just gonna do if I'm want to go away for
a weekend I'm [ __ ] so i go to i go i
tech I email you I said what's you just
shown Shanghai who's the guy this guy he
was like yeah I do shown Shanghai but
also my brother is a like neurosurgeon
and he's very involved in the
transcranial the TMS community oh wow
and I know that yeah so it's a new thing
so he's like if you want to do
TMS while you're here and do the show
that Chinese TM am and Jesus so yeah man
so last week I did that [ __ ] Chinese
TMS bro and I'm in a Chinese hospital in
Shenzhen China and I'm getting so the
first time I did TMS was here but his
brother's got this brain mapping
software where they can see what parts
of your brain are communicating well
with other parts of your brain so they
basically found that the back of my
brain which the serotonin Center wasn't
communicating well with the rest of my
brain so I got [ __ ] zapped in the
back yeah and on the right side for for
five basic 10 sessions a day for four
days straight right yeah I went and did
the damn thing they can sew a [ __ ]
sweater with your tongue on that yeah
I'm [ __ ] I'm on that [ __ ] that
unlimited [ __ ] I'm on the unlimited pen
right now did you feel that what what
happened I feel good I don't want to do
this thing where like I'm in love I
don't I'm just like I feel good I think
it's better but I don't wanna
it was elective it wasn't like I was
like I couldn't I'm just like a zombie
in life I I want I'm trying to optimize
my trying to optimize my [ __ ] life
yes to feel good not to produce not to
rise & grind not to make a bigger profit
than I did last year just feel good have
a fun time yeah enjoy myself do weird
[ __ ] just you should go to Shenzhen
China go to Hong Kong go to [ __ ]
Shanghai I love hearing that man cuz
sometimes I forget that that is the goal
that that the goal is to feel good
sometimes it's like I know it originally
I knew yeah but sometimes then I forget
that that what an important goal that is
you know it's like these are all these
other kind of ways to say it and ways to
like you know replace it almost get put
in you put it you organize it it gets
organized in a way cuz you think about
when you're like 10 during the summer
right oh yeah what were you trying to do
you just get up just try to get some
[ __ ] poppin yeah just write it in short
just try to get some [ __ ] poppin I try
to put your sandals on Earth bike around
[ __ ] these guys are over there and
then at the edge of the woods yeah
they're doing some [ __ ] then you go over
here you get some candy you get and you
can keep doing that yes they a different
way yeah just you just can do it are you
work and you do all that stuff but just
see what else is just get some [ __ ] what
do you like doing do that I like doing
stand-up but here's what I realized I
like doing I like doing stand-up I like
directing commercials I like writing
jokes and talking to black people too
talking of course
and I like just like just [ __ ]
[ __ ] around watching [ __ ] on the
internet going on the inital online
three hours you like you're kind of a
little bit of a Magellan on the UH
mental health front a little bit I mean
it seems yeah nobody talks about it no
and that's the other thing is nobody
talks about it yeah and I don't have any
shame I don't think it's any weirder I
don't think that having depression is a
weakness I don't think it's any weaker
than having tendonitis yeah oh I'm just
like I don't know let's see I'll try to
treat it I'm not gonna make it like I
don't I'm not trying to make it a heavy
thing yeah but I whenever I see you I
try to talk about your feelings or your
emotion it's like cuz dude that's the
thing the reason why that clip of you is
popular is because everyone wants to
talk about it but most places it's kind
of like a you know I'm sure after shows
you have as many people that just like
you because you're funny and and and and
quirky and then there's also people are
like hey man can I talk to you about
such-and-such
yeah a lot of people come out a lot of
people are struggling yeah yeah I didn't
realize that I guess I that so many
people were having tough times but then
I look at all the people that are dying
to meds and dying to this and that yeah
man people really are struggling yeah do
you think that one of the reasons a lot
of young men are struggling is because
just like the way we've changed from
being like really like limbic like
things we need to do hunt get milk get
honey get you know yeah you know attack
stuff do stuff be they are connected to
the earth and then now we've become this
separate sort of just it's almost like
we're just like a strong thing or
housecats
being contained yes we're indoor cats
now so it's [ __ ] scary
well yeah it'll make you start to you
know what we're you know it's a these
are all luxury problems right right yeah
no they're luxury problems they're not
saying it like you I'm not compliant way
it's the this goes from the slavery
America for the richest American most of
our shits taking care of our basic needs
right yeah and if I don't want to do
[ __ ] you can
[ __ ] let the government give you
money every mommy yeah it's like you you
can you can get taken care of in this
country yes so once you've got your
basic needs taken care of then you start
getting philosophical right and start
eating away and like am i pleased right
am i happy as much as where I'm [ __ ]
on the bar conversation like no but
problems with a robbery are we a side
effect but a problem is a problem it's
right if your problem is I need water
today or your problem is or I brain
doesn't feel good today yeah it that's
still a problem yeah and I think I would
that what I do is I try to treat it the
same way I treat it I'm hungry which is
I need food I need some I'm gonna do
something to treat my brain right I'm
going to [ __ ] China bro yeah they got
them good zappers over there I'm going
to China like that I always think that
so that's kind of my thinking yeah like
we're set up enough that we can just
even if you work 60 hours a week that's
do you still have a lot of you still a
decent amount of free time like that you
and what do you want to do with it
to treat the rest of it like the your
hunting just what are you hunting for
yeah if it's you're hunting for answers
there's plenty of [ __ ] you can do
there's plenty of [ __ ] you can listen to
plenty of books you can read plenty of
12-step stuff you can meditate you can
pray you can there's so much [ __ ] you
can do that's not like yeah there's a
lot of new therapies out there things
are coming out all the time there's new
ways that people are thinking you know
there's podcast people to listen to
people that share like share what's
going on with them good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one